er liebe zuschauer ich bin heute morgen
aufgewacht mit einer whatsapp von einem
freund die war jakob vielen dank dafür
ich habe mich nämlich köstlich amüsiert
er hatte mir an artikeln geschickt von
der new york times und das john kornblum
zitiert worden der ehemalige
us-botschafter hier in deutschland und
er hat olaf scholz verglichen mit einem
topf kochendes wasser aber der kopf der
topf kochen in wasser sei spannender als
urlaubs ich habe tatsächlich laut
gelacht mir flog der porit außen und
danach war ich allerdings auch gleich
wieder ein bisschen gedämpft und meldet
getrübt denn er hat gar nicht so unrecht
mit dem was er da sagt auch nichts er
überspitzt war das problem ist in der
tat wir haben meiner meinung nach keine
starken charaktere in dieser politik ich
sehe sie nicht ist sie ganz besonders
nicht wenn in drei spitzenkandidaten und
ich habe ein bisschen das gefühl und ein
bisschen die sorge ein bisschen die
angst wenn wir es nicht schaffen in
deutschland große persönlichkeiten
einzubinden die aus der wirtschaft
kommen die aus der kultur kommt die aus
dem sport vielleicht auch möglicherweise
kommen und die sich engagieren für die
etablierten parteien das uns
glücklicherweise italienische
verhältnisse irgendwann drohen auch hier
in deutschland weil es immer mehr die
chance gibt später parteien über die
fünf-prozent-hürde zu bringen und dafür
graust es mir tatsächlich so willig
deutschland nicht sehen mit am ende
einer vier oder fünf parteien regierung
weil es anders gar nicht mehr möglich
ist also mein klarer punkt den ich
setzen will ist last leute die nicht
politik gelernt haben aber die politik
können auch in politische ämter und
nicht mit der politischen karriereleiter
von kleinauf oben krabbeln kali ich kann
dir nur zustimmen absolut und wir haben
das ja auch gesehen was ist passiert bei
friedrich merz wie viele widerstände gab
es für friedrich merz der in der politik
war der auch hohe ämter spitzenämter
fraktionsvorsitz im deutschen bundestag
bekleidet hat dann ausgestiegen ist aus
der politik und mehr oder weniger
freiwillig oder unfreiwillig je nachdem
wie man da glauben kann der dann
zurückkommen wollte und eigentlich auf
eine mauer des widerstands in der
eigenen partei gestoßen ist es gibt
viele in der cdu die gesagt haben mensch
toll dass wir da es aber das sogenannte
establishment also die funktionsträger
im bundesvorstand im präsidium dann
natürlich gesagt jetzt kommt er wieder
der
weltbeste der beste zwischenrufer das
war wohl bei immer wenn es hieß ja der
macht ja nur zwischenrufe von der
seitenlinie ja was ist denn das also
wahrscheinlich hat friedrich merz mehr
ahnung von der geopolitik
der ministerpräsident in deutschland
zusammen weil er für ein weltkonzern
tätig war absolut also von daher ich
stimme ich dir voll und ganz zu und
überein dass wir den sprung aus anderen
bereichen ob es jetzt der sport ist oder
ob es die wirtschaft ist viel stärker
erleichtern müssten und ein klima
eigentlich eine kultur haben müssten und
man muss das befahren man muss es auch
ermöglichen dass man eben tatsächlich
quereinsteiger und eben nicht ganz unten
auch im freundeskreis ich habe freunde
die sind bei der cdu bei den grünen bei
der fdp wir sind da relativ offen hier
haben sich sogar politisch engagieren
wollen und das soll jetzt überhaupt
nicht arrogant klingt gar nicht tut es
aber möglicherweise aber wenn die dann
in den kreis ort verbannt dann aktiv
werden und man rede wirklich 34 stunden
ob jetzt der mülleimer aufgestellt
werden darf oder nicht das frustriert
halte dass das sind teilweise anwälte
die auch gutes geld verdienen die bereit
wären es aufzugeben tatsächlich aber
nicht mit mitte dreißig ende dreißig
ganz unten einsteigen und über jahre
hinweg darüber diskutieren ist ja
mittlerweile schon spät ne geht schon
mit 20 jahren das ist ja trotzdem ab so
ich finde es lustig weil ich glaube dass
das wirklich was sehr sehr deutsch ist
also meiner zeit in der in der new york
auslandskorrespondent habe ich auch
amerikaner getroffen ja gesagt haben wie
bei euch deutschen ist es was schlecht
ist wenn man viel geld hat das macht ein
zu einem schlechten politik aber uns ist
das gegenteil der fall das zeigt auch
dass man erfolgreich ist dass man
irgendwie drauf hat auch zu wirtschaften
und so weiter mache ich mir stimmt das
ist wirklich sehr deutsch aber ich oute
mich auch als deutsch ich würde mich
lieber kein entertainer als kanzler aber
wenn das gehen kann ist doch ist
hoffentlich vor schluss davor gemacht
hat bin okay und ich denke die ganze
zeit an schwamb und mit angst und bange
also sehen möchte auf keinen fall da wir
stehen bliebe aber im firmen- und vom
spiel und auch zum bruder vielleicht
nicht so unterhaltsam ist und ich glaube
so geht's einfach vielen tausend üblich
nee nee ich möchte von einem anständigen
menschen und politiker
regiert werden und das traue ich also
meine tochter so sind meine markus söder
habe ich müssen das problem dass ich ihn
sehr als showman und als sehr ich mache
es für die show so ne also mir manchmal
zurückhaltend merkel ist ja auch also
viele sagen jetzt auch scholz geht in
die merck in richtung im prinzip war er
der nachfolger für merkel lastet auch
die sind alle eher zurückhaltend und
früher fand ich das auch nervig
inzwischen denke ich ich finds gut ich
möchte lieber so jemanden das ist ich
habe mehr vater koppel brauchen wir mehr
brauchen wir mehr unterhaltungs typen
brauchen wir mehr
persönlichkeiten die man kennt also auch
ein bisschen mehr entertainment im wagen
ich glaube es nicht eine frage des
entertainments ich glaube die deutschen
mit ihrer geschichte wenn man die
letzten 150 jahre anschaut also da war
ja gleichsam ein horror thriller zum
teil dabei also die deutschen sehnen
sich schon noch solidität das sind
solide leute aber wo sie natürlich
völlig recht haben das ist ein typisches
unbehagen dass ich nicht nur in
deutschland spüren dass man einfach das
gefühl hat dass diese ganze polit
apparat eine verkrustete ein
korallenriff ist von leuten die eben
ihren auftrag als politiker sich für das
wohl der bürger einzusetzen an die
bürger zu denken nicht an sich selbst
und an ihre wunderbaren diäten und an
dieser wunderbaren dienstwagen und auch
diese dinge dass eben diese politbetrieb
sich völlig abgekoppelt hat von den
leuten und das ist ja das werden sich
der punkt ist eben dinge dass diese
politbetrieb dass auch wenn amerika
gesehen nehmen sie einen trump das ist
ja eine idealtypische quereinsteiger da
hat sich ja das ganze system gegen den
zusammengeklaut vielleicht hat er das
eine und dann drei hat dazu beigetragen
aber
nein aber die politiker sind heute ein
kartell die ihre macht verteidigen und
gegen jeden eindringling also mit
inquisitoren gesichtern und
scharfschützen augen das alles weg ist
und das ist ein problem
und dieses unbehagen spüren wir
natürlich geriet das siehst du auch an
zu einem tanzlied rielle wo man das
gefühl hat da reden drei spitzenbeamte
konnte die sanierung einmal
kehrichtverbrennungsanlage einmal muss
ich abwägen müssen städten habe ich
meine wir reden über die idee neue.de
also die größte firma die es in diesem
lande gibt es das land selber keiner von
den dreien glauben wir doch im ernst
hätte draußen so wie sie auftreten eine
chance einen großen posten bei einer
großen firma zu bekommen weil es da auch
zugehört einen gewissen charakter als
führungskraft spiel meine sache ich will
nur ein paar jeans ist ein punkt noch
machen den ich jetzt vergessen habe und
deswegen gewicht
in diese politik hat doch keine dieser
spitzenleute in seinem leben jemand
schon jemals schon einen bleistift
verkauft die haben nur politische
entschuldigung wirtschaftliche erfahrung
und das ist das problem heute schlagen
ist durch eine erbschaft story oslo in
dem die wirtschaft ist in der politik
nicht vertreten die in eben jener auf
und ich habe mal die hre legt kali weil
du aus dem sport kommt da hab ich mir
überlegt ok wen kann ich dir heute abend
vorschlagen wenn wir brauchen werde ich
vor bevor wir jemanden wenn wir antreten
würde wenn mich eine gute minute an die
seite stellen ja ja so dass los ich bin
gespannt jetzt kommt auto ja ja ja ja
und deswegen glaube ich es ihnen ja aber
es wäre doch toll dass weder web.de
glaube ich habe die hsh und der us
vorwahlen haben glaube ich schon einen
guten sind ein guter mechanismus denn es
könnte ja auch eine partei einfach sagen
wir stehen in einem intern
verlassen olaf scholz gegen jürgen klopp
und was auch immer gegen lars klingbeil
einfach mal aus und dann kann doch die
parteibasis bestimmen würde keiner
wetten dass hat es ja alles nicht
gegeben dieses us for system das glaube
ich ja nur demokratische prinzipien ja
ich kann mich auch als republikaner bei
der demokraten register umgekehrt und
kann dann mit bestimmen wenig als besten
kandidaten und nicht weil du dich über
drei jahrzehnte naja aber hochwertig
genau es ist ein so hat trump ja auch
geschafft als geschäftsmann dass er
danach ein bisschen kritik daran dass
ich da gerne an ihren und viel gelder
und darüber aber entschuldigung
berlin weißensee aber das geld ist das
ist doch wir haben doch jetzt auch
millionen an spenden eingenommen haben
die parteien eingenommen und geben es
jetzt aus an dieser wahlkampf ist der
teuerste wahlkampf stimmt die wir bisher
hatten also wer glaubt im wahlkampf geht
ohne geld auch bei den social media
ausgaben sehen wir ja einen dramatischen
anstieg über die vergangenen jahre also
wahlkampf ist ohne geld nicht habe ich
ein punkt wird ihnen jetzt hab ich
nämlich wieder den glauben doch und da
sind wir uns doch alle einig hier im
tisch politik darf doch nicht nur von
politikern gemacht sein die über 30
jahre in einem politischen system
gewesen sind das kann doch es sollen die
besten leute auf die besten position es
nicht wenn der fonds sind fest von
überzeugt ob das im sport ist ob das in
der kultur ist ob natürlich in der
wirtschaft ist dass es da draußen sehr
sehr viele tolle frauen und männer gibt
die im politischen system helfen würden
sie kommen nur nicht ran und ehrlicher
weise haben sie es halt eben auch nicht
nötig weil sie halt eben in einem
anderen leben erfolgreich waren deswegen
müssen wir wege finden um die um diese
leute daran zu las und las mich an mein
traum dass kloppo mein traum stellt euch
vor steffi graf als familienministerin
als bundespräsident war das ist ja nicht
ausgeschlossen armin laschet ecommerce
vegas hat und können sagen steffi home
office
dass jemand im home office das land
regiert als steffi graf schon
schlimm wir also jetzt noch nicht nein
ich meine man sich gesagt haben man
könnte sich auch um den amerikanern
etwas inspirieren der tromp bräuchte auf
die palme bringt was hat trump gemacht
im ersten moment hat ein super erfolg
und das kabinett zusammengestellt von
leuten die wirklich hervorragend sind
die weitere kantone hat ein team von
auch praktikern leuten aus den richtigen
leben geben schon mal ein bleistift
verkauft haben wer angestellt wie kein
tolles team und er hat durch sein
extremes verhalten dann immer noch die
kritik der medien so weit auf sich
gelenkt dass seine minister in aller
ruhe arbeiten konnten also die
amerikaner haben das gezeigt wie du auch
quereinsteiger einbinden kannst denn
etwas musst du wissen wenn du in die
politik einsteigt politik ist extrem
anspruchsvoll und da habe ich zum
beispiel großen respekt vor frau merkel
auch wenn ich vieles an ihrer politik
kritisieren dieses durchhaltevermögen
und darauf diese ausdauer ja auch das
fast übermenschlich wir wünschten uns
sie wäre vielleicht etwas früher
gegangen dann wäre es der cdu vielleicht
nicht ganz wäre die nicht an dem punkt
wo sie jetzt ist aber diese qualitäten
sind halt auch sehr wenige leute bereit
aufzubringen aber wenn ich in dieser
runde blicke da sehe ich eine show am
ende wir
potenziale frei ich glaube der politiker
der sagt wo es ist alles so schwer der
muss nicht mehr antreten also vorbei
weil sie mitleid würde ich hier
einsteigen haben aber wenn ich euch noch
länger klagen höre werde ich
möglicherweise in der deutschen staffel
ganz kurz eine letzte schlussrunde fing
gleich einmal kurz unterbrechen kay
unterberg also schlägt vor dass steffi
graf sportministerin also seiner familie
ministerin soll da hast du einen wunsch
werk soll aus seiner sicht ich sagen rob
bundeskanzler sogar herr köppel hin
können sie sich vorstellen ein extern
sportlerin sportler roger federer und
sich mit mein revier mal irgendein neues
biologisches gentechnologisch verfahren
entwickelt haben das wie franz josef
strauß wieder beleben könnten dann
könnte ich mir vorstellen dass er diesen
augiasstall den wir jetzt haben wieder
aufräumen könnte ich denke jogi hat zeit
jetzt oder ymca
zuwachssparen familie oder
ich wäre für den biotech gründer
[Musik]